السعودية والدفاع عن اراضيه
التقارير اكدت توقيع ثماني عشرة
من الحصول على سلاح نووي. فيما
اكد بايدن التزام بلاده بدعم امن
لهاج روسية في عدة مناطق وتوقعات
غربية بان تغير منظومة انتو
الاوكراني يعلن استلامه منظومة
الصواريخ الجديدة ويؤكد تصديه
تتوجه الى مضاعفة استخدام الفحم
والنفط في انتاج الكهرباء.
وستفعل المانيا كل ما تستطيع
لخفض الانبعاثات. الجيش
سفنتي سير المعارك في اوكرانيا.
بعد ان اعلنها الرئيس الجزائري
مرجانية. عدد سكانها لا يتجاوز
الفا واربعمائة نسمة. وبعد ثلاثة
بوتين لم يعطي الضوء الاخضر
لاردوغان ليبدأ عمليته في سوريا.
تم اعادة افتتاح الحدود بين تونس
والجزائر بعد اغلاق دام لاكثر من
المستشار الالماني يقول ان تنشيط
محطات الطاقة بالفحم قرار مؤقت
العملية العسكرية التركية في
سوريا فبحسب التقارير الروسية
سنتين. تعهد بايدن مع العاهل
السعودي وولي عهده على منع ايران
روسيا وتنفي فرض قيود على بيع
معدات زراعية لموسكو. موسكو توقف
اتفاقية بين البلدين شملت الطاقة
والاستثمار والاتصالات والفضاء
العقوبات الاوروبية المتوقعة
لتقليل اعتماد دول الاتحاد على
الولايات المتحدة تبحر لضمان
حرية في بحر الصين ولتحدي ما
البرلمان السيريلانكي يعلن قبول
استقالة رئيس البلاد المانيا
للامريكان لن نتهاون في امر
سيادتنا هل فهمتم? غرفة اوروبا
الاجتماعات والقمم بالشرق الاوسط
ايها الامريكان. قبل ذلك كان
اعتراض موجات الريديو والموجات
الكهرومغناطيسية. الغرفة ستخضع
وثلاثون قائدا. وفريق الدعم
الفني وطاقم العمل بالمطعم.
الاقليمية بحسب بكين. عادت اليوم
المدمرة ذاتها لتبحر قرب جزر
اجتماعه مع بايدن. فهل يجنح
المحتل الاسرائيلي للسلام؟
الحديث عن تشكيل التحالف الامني
او ما يعرف باسم الناتو العربي
والصحة لكن هذا كله لا يغطي
الفضائح التي احرجت الرئيس
انور قرقاش ان دولة الامارات
تبحث ارسال سفير الى ايران مع
سبرتليا المتنازع عليها في بحر
الصين الجنوبي. لمحاولة اثبات ان
الذي اكد ان العراق ترفض قطعيا
الانضمام الى الناتو العربي.
كان لهم رأي اخر فمثلا رئيس
الوزراء العراقي مصطفى الكاظمي
سعيها الى اعادة بناء العلاقات
معها. وبينما تهدف امريكا لحرب
محورا اساسيا من محاور المناقشات
التي سبقت زيارة بايدن للمنطقة
ايام فقط من طرد الصين للمدمرة
الامريكية بنفولز من مياهها
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس قد
اعلن استعداده لصنع السلام مع في
الغاز الروسي. الغرفة السرية
تتسع لمئة شخص منهم اربعة
ايران بالناتو العربي اكثر فاكثر
من طهران. اذا فما فائدة
البيت الابيض على شيء ملموس في
هذا الشأن? لا لا يبدو ذلك. كان
والغرب جزر باراسيل في بحر الصين
الجنوبي. نزاع تاريخي بين الصين
المنطقة دولة الامارات قال
الدبلوماسي للرئيس الاماراتي
السرية. بتكلفة تصل الى ثمانية
ملايين يورو. الاتحاد الاوروبي
تقول انها قيود فرضتها الصين لكن
اصحاب العيون الضيقة يقولون
ياتي مع تزايد المخاوف تنصت
الكريملين على محادثات سرية حول
صدمة امريكية يا سادة على الجانب
الاخر احد اقوى حلفاء امريكا في
المحور الامني الاقليمي الذي من
شأنه ان يشمل اسرائيل. فالعرب
لفحص قبل اي اجتماع وستكون جاهزة
عام الفين واربعة وعشرين.
وستحط بقفص عازل للحد من مخاطر
تسرب الانبعاثات قادرة على
الاحداث والتطورات. الولايات
المتحدة ترفع بعض العقوبات عن
تصفه واشنطن بقيود تفرضه برازيل
تتكون من مائة وثلاثين جزيرة
الانسحاب الامريكي من منطقة
الشرق الاوسط خلال السنوات
وست دول يؤججه ابحار مدمرات
امريكية في المنطقة في تحد لما
يخطط لبناء غرفة سرية في بروكسل
لمقاومة التجسس الروسي. المخطط
يحسد عليه مع محاولات من الرئيس
الامريكي بالرد في المواقف
وصار مسارا للسخرية حول العالم.
فالسعودية اكبر مصدري النفط في
لكنهم اجابوا بانهم قد حاسبوا
بالفعل اما الصورة الابرز فكانت
العالم لن تزيد من انتاجها ولن
تستجيب للطلبات الامريكية. وفي
بايدن. يبدو ان بايدن عدا بخفي
حنين من زيارته للشرق الاوسط
المواقف التي تعرض لها رئيس اقوى
دولة في العالم. كشف حساب زيارة
زالت السعودية منبوذة? ولي العهد
السعودي وضع بايدن في موقف لا
واشنطن تستفز بكين مجددا. نقطة
مواجهة عسكرية محتملة بين الصين
الامريكي. حين تصافح معه بقبضة
يده حتى انه لم يصافحه يده وكانت
لكن الرئيس الامريكي اخفق في
الحصول على التزامات بانشاء هذا
وعدم ترك فراغ تستغله روسيا
والصين وايران. فهل حصل سيد
الاخرى لكن الصحافة لن يتوقف
سيلان حبرها لفترة طويلة عن
اول قضية سأله عنها بايدن هي
قضية خاشقجي ليحرج السعوديين
والعناق. لكن ذلك انتهى عند
استقبال بن سلمان للرئيس
الامريكان قضية خاشقجي لمساومة
السعودية? وقت اخر بالعودة لقضية
الصحفية شيرين ابو عقلة. فهل هو
رد بالمثل من ولي العهد السعودي
ابتسامة ابن سلمان بعد سؤال
موجها لبايدن ايها الرئيس هل ما
العربية السعودية ابتداء من
مراسم الاستقبال التي بسبب
كما في سجن ابو غريب في العراق
وعدم محاسبة واشنطن لقتلة
الماضية بدا واضحا ان بايدن اراد
تأكيد عودة امريكا الى المنطقة
ومع كل استقبال للقادة العرب
كانت تظهر لقطات من الضحك
بايدن لا تحتمل وخلال استقبال
ولي العهد السعودي في مطار الملك
عبدالعزيز بجدة زعماء ومسؤولين
عرب استعدادا لعقد القمة
الخليجية بحضور بايدن ورئيس
العراق ورئيس مصر وملك الاردن
العالم. بايدن لم يلقى الترحيب
الحار الذي حظي به سلفه ترامب
وخاصة في استقبال محمد بن سلمان
الذي يبدو انه صار محورا
التباطؤ في فرش البساط المخصص
لاستقبال الزعماء ما بقي داخل
للاحاديث الجانبية. فيما بعد
هناك كانت السخرية من الرئيس
طائرته وقتا طويلا ويا له من
موقف محرج لزعيم اقوى دولة في
انتقاص من بايدن. جو بايدن يتعرض
للسخرية خلال زيارته للمملكة
خاشقجي. هناك رد ابن سلمان على
بايدن بان امريكا ارتكبت اخطاء
مهم. فما الذي يقصده الرئيس
الامريكي يا ترى? هل يخبئ
ان يخرج من ذلك الموضوع وقال
لماذا لا تتحدثون يا رفاق عن شيء
بن سلمان بقتل الصحفي خاشقجي?
بايدن رد على الفور. لا. ثم حاول
بايدن غير المباشر. بعد ان زار
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وفلسطين تعلن استعدادها للسلام
مع الكيان الاسرائيلي. هجوم
قاله وزير الخارجية السعودي انك
لم تتهم ولي العهد السعودي محمد
حالها. الجزائر تفتح احضانها
لتونس والامارات تخطب ود ايران
باعصاب الصين وتختبر صبرها؟ ومن
جانب اخر تسحب واشنطن العقوبات
الامريكي ما الذي يجري في الشرق
الاوسط يا اصدقاء هكذا تعرض
الرئيس الامريكي للسخرية في
زيارته للسعودية؟ امريكا تتلاعب
على موسكو؟ ايعقل هذا؟ هذه هي
الغرفة السرية التي ينوي الاتحاد
السعودية طرحت الصحافة عليه
سؤالا اثار من الجدل. هل صحيح ما
هل العرب الى الطرف الروسي
وحلفائه لعدم ضمان الجانب
بناءها لصد تجسس الكرملين
والمانيا تعيش مجاعة الطاقة وهذا
اذا فلماذا اجتمع بايدن بالقادة
العرب? تتسائل الصحافة العالمية.
Biden.
don't you guys talk about
something that matters?
العرب ينفون قضية الناتو العربي
ويمدون ايديهم للسلام مع ايران.
truth? No. He was like the fist
pump mister president. Why
Crown Prince of Kafchogi's
murder. Is he telling the
الامريكي.
The Saudi Foreign Minister says
he didn't hear you accuse the